I know that you started out doing you
were DJ for quite a while and then I
found out that you're still doing it
you're still doing DJing is that right
yes yeah and you and you really enjoy it
you love it I love DJ I don't understand
how someone starts being a DJ that's
something that always confused me like
how do you begin being a DJ okay well
the traditional ways that you learn how
to DJ and then you practice very hard oh
you could do what I did
and I I was at an event I was already a
young up-and-coming TV host back in the
day and I was standing at this event
watching the DJ and the DJ didn't have
to talk to anyone and I have horrible
social anxiety so I was like that's the
job you will die it's how you go DJ just
cuz you don't have to have a
conversation yes oh my god and you get
to pick the music it's wonderful so I
got talking to the woman who was running
the event and she said and I was telling
her how much I enjoyed the music and we
started talking about music and she said
you know do you DJ and I was like
because I'm a sociopath yes I do and you
you had never done it me no and because
there's woman books all the biggest
events in London she was like oh my god
I need a DJ next week for Elton John's
birthday party one week to learn how to
DJ wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute first of all this woman is
terrible at her job
cuz she's literally like Giudice yes
they do then you will be the DJ at Elton
Tom's birthday party without doing any
research I'd like seriously I was I am
trash and I have been a DJ for eight
years
I'm Jason Mendoza I'm not too honey so
how did it go at Elton John's birthday
party and you pulled it off obviously it
was okay
Sir Elton was not thrilled but it was
fine and it kicked off an eight-year
career so I must have done something
right so maybe Elton doesn't want to
hear any DJ maybe he wants to hear
someone sit down and play the piano baby
yeah put it on him not you Elton yeah
let's make sure that goes viral well I'm
really I'm really blown away that you
just said yet that takes a lot of guts
to say yes because in this business many
times you have to say yes I can without
being able to do it and now you have to
find your way yeah that's been my whole
career I mean even with a good place
I've never acted before the audition was
the first time I'd ever acted and I was
there in a room with Mike sure he was
like have you um you can improv right
and I was like yes he made me improv
with him for ten minutes which was the
worst feeling on earth and somehow I
survived that but my whole career is
just been ten years of saying yes to
everything apart from anal but like
[Applause]
this is like I got it you got to leave
something you know you gotta leave some
room for growth no I don't think it's
gonna grow this is why they didn't let
me come on by myself plus I just lost
all my rest my questions hope this card
is about and you just put out an outline
with four subsets you just come up with
the answer where do we go now triple the
mystery out of our conversation